[Applause]
did you talk about
ellen show leaving oh we did yeah we did
it
did we kill ellen dude i think if you
people make ellen take a dirt nap i
think
if you beef with the flag or two
podcasts it's just not it's not gonna
work out for you it's not that good for
you bro yeah there's not a long life
attached to it she said it wasn't a
challenge anymore
what was it what if doing her show yeah
because i'm sure the first
23 years are super tough you walking out
there and [ __ ] dancing that must have
been so tough
it wasn't a challenge anymore what an
odd
completely unself-aware reaction because
if daytime talk shows are one thing
it's challenging yeah i mean i don't
know if it is or it isn't but like
that's not the reason you don't have a
shoney yeah yeah right yeah
the facade is is over like people know
that you're not
nice that you were playing a character
that's why it's over
you didn't really make the decision the
people made the decision if we're
talking about challenges
isn't it kind of a challenge to take the
ratings that are taking a nosedive and
bring them back up isn't that
that's the challenge that's a challenge
so if you're on a challenge ellen here's
one
yeah lift your [ __ ] what is she thinking
right now wanting that show to tank this
whole time
and now that it finally is she's like
it's not a challenge this is
this is what i've been waiting for i
finally achieved it i finally did it
like i did
everything stupid possible i would just
scare people every episode they kept
coming on
every episode they come on i have
someone jump out of a box and scare them
they keep coming on the [ __ ] thing
i mean i make the people dance in the
audience i dance with them stupid
nothing changes i'm an [ __ ] to
everybody some guy was eating a tuna
sandwich i told him go [ __ ] himself
i fired him i said nobody tuna on the on
on the whole show you can't eat tuna
everybody gets fired
i was the worst boss ever the ratings
kept going up
up up up up and then finally flagrant
two podcasts
talks about it it goes viral and my
dream has finally come true
she's always wanted to show i mean she
was mean to people and it kept doing
better you're welcome ellen
if you want to come onto the show you
and prince harry let's have an episode
absolutely
come on the show we want you here in
your deep eye sockets
dude she got some deep [ __ ] eyes bro
skeletor eyes that girl
have you seen her dude it's like she
looks young but her eyes
are retreating back into her skull
they're probably hiding from her mean
ass bro she's got a boy she's going to
yell at him
when porsha punches her in her face and
she just looks at the fist make eye
contact
it doesn't make eye contact it just
makes contact and then doesn't even
blink
that's it socket contact that's it deep
sockets
deep socks deep sockets dude can't trust
her
can't trust her
you